what's that for what I have here the
solution any blood problem the greatest
combat in the blood is grown right here
in the vertical variation of California
if I have a column what you wait for me
an invitation for RSVP has Teddy likes
the product you look at he's six foot
six Mary Jo no it takes you height you
prancy get on your chin damn to give you
his best shot turn a dagger stop come on
man
right now as he is antifreeze antifreeze
has a common effect on the lungs and the
thorax you don't want to adjust this
orally and you definitely don't want to
rub it in your eyes now you can ask
China mix about that
once you get that off there spinning man
stop spinning
you know confuse him fire hitting below
the belt yeah I thought that was illegal
man live stuck on a school bus that's
illegal
that kid man without let's go let me in
on a little secret
do you know bounce art equilibrium if
they placed precisely behind the ear was
it prongs I might use Franklin am I
gonna tell you're hot out your ass when
this fights over
yes now we got a reputation man dad Adam
hates me come on now we didn't come this
far for nothing
Victor accent
don't quit I will do quitting on me man
well he jab and I'm seeing room for a
headbutt
Oh what is that man out of our grappling
ha may have to place your piece right
here why'd you put a bullet in my
suspect Sam fighting Danny man I ain't
even listen to you you acting like this
your birthright this is my first fight
your first fight earth plane just hit
the tower you mean to tell me we got all
this training that's not all this time
but this time you're gonna repay us what
we paid you the boot dog crazy man what
we're saying on the heavy bag I was just
getting some cardio you just tagging
along
listen cardio man this is boxing I want
you to get in there firm about a net and
then face off or whatever thing you got
to that level